[Music]
hey Bill its Martin Africa right here
I'm studying medical chemistry and I
have two questions to be answered first
one is a question how would you probably
solve the problem of still growing
population and the second question way
important is okay hi
so Martina what I'll get to your second
question at the end the growing
population is a problem but notice that
the rate that the population is growing
human population is growing is slowing
down and this is almost certainly not so
much a consequence of finite resources
which is what people like Malthus
speculated late in the 18th century it's
not a question of finite resources it's
it's apparently raising the standard of
living of women and girls people like
you as women and girls get better
educated they have fewer kids and the
kids they do have have more resources so
they're better taken care of and they
are more successful so what we want to
do in my world over here in science
education is get women and girls around
the world as educated as best we can as
fast as we can so that there will be
more resources for per person in the
coming years the Popular's population is
almost certainly going to go to 9
billion humans it very well may go to 10
billion and apparently the earth has
enough resources for that and we just
have to redistribute or reconfigure the
way we use energy water and the way we
distribute information these are
solvable problems and I'm excited to be
working on them every day like even
right now I'm working on so how do we go
about doing this it's important to keep
in mind that if somebody in
Nazaire has five kids the impact of each
of those five kids on the world's
environment is far far less than the
effect of me on the world's environment
I lived in the United States in a
developed country we use energy like
crazy we use clean water like crazy we
are that or most of us have access to
the Internet
my environmental impact is way higher
because I use so I fly around in planes
I got here on an electric subway train
we're on the electric computer systems
right now and so we're on electric
computer systems right now so my affect
in the environments way higher than kids
in the developing world but what we want
to do is not do less for people in the
developed world we want to do more for
people in the developing world with less
we want to use our resources more
efficiently and that's where young
people like you come in you're studying
chemistry and biology you are going to
make the changes to our agricultural
systems our disease management and the
way we educate your the people in your
class and the people coming behind you
internment women and girls we're going
to change all that so I talked about
this all the time we want renewably
produced reliable electricity for
everybody in the world we want clean
water for everybody in the world and we
want access to information to the
Internet for everybody in the world
because when you provide those things
people have a chance to get educated
they have access to educational
materials they have access to good food
and a healthy lifestyle because they
don't have to combat diseases as much
and they become more productive and so
it is women like you that are going to
make all this happen now as far as
whether or not I'll marry you I have to
say it's unlikely I want to say
categorically no because I got a glimpse
of you but I just wouldn't I wouldn't
count on it I just wouldn't care we live
in different countries work from
different cultures my assessment based
on the videos were different ages with
different life experiences and you would
just want something else in about 15
minutes but thank you I'm flattered for
the question
carry on
[Music]